also noch zurückhaltend aber das ganze
ich habe gesagt ich bin nicht neidisch
aber auf essen gehen willst du hier
gesehen haben vielleicht tauschen wissen
auszumachen dass italien nie sagen mir
jetzt ich heute einfach möglich dass es
wieder auf vollgas wir sollen auch
urlaubs 43 eben aber wenn man hier
wieder vielleicht essen gehen könnte
aber das ist ja dass dort noch lange
sehr sehr lange noch kann ich zu sagen
wir wollen jetzt noch mal nach schweden
schauen denn wir haben menschen mit
unserer kollegin annika rasch gesprochen
und schweden ist dieser corona krise ein
ganz besonderer ort gewesen denn dort
wurde vieles anders gemacht als hier bei
uns in deutschland und anderen
eu-ländern und jannika du hast jetzt
auch einen gast bei dir und erzählt uns
etwas mehr darüber wie jetzt in zukunft
geplant wird in schweden vor allem was
die impfungen angeht ja also noch sind
reisen und kultur hier in schweden
wirklich frei mehr oder weniger
aber das soll sich jetzt ändern denn
seit einer woche plant dänemark 1
digital impfpass einzuführen
und da schweden jetzt nachgezogen das
heißt es könnte sein dass wir nicht mehr
so einfach einreisen können und das aber
auch die schweden selbst nicht mehr so
einfach konzerte besuchen können wenn
sie denn nicht geimpft sind und darüber
möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit dem
schwedischen digitalen minister anders
gemacht und ihn einmal fragen was das
mit diesem impfpass auf sich hat und was
eigentlich los geht müsste man die
einführung eines solchen corona in
france is was bedeutet dieser passt und
man wird das beginnen nun die bedeutung
ist dass man nachweisen kann dass man
die impfung erhalten hat und wenn man
geimpft worden ist
dann können beispielsweise
fluggesellschaften auch einen solchen
nachweis verlangen damit sie reisen
können und das wird wahrscheinlich auch
in anderen bereichen
und wann wird das beginne nun wir haben
die arbeit jetzt begonnen und wir hoffen
dass das alles bis zum sommer also
müsste man hat gerade gesagt dass man
damit im sommer starten möchte mit der
einführung des passes und der praktisch
zur eintrittskarte wird eben für
das können dann eventuell die airlines
selbst entscheiden aber eben auch für
kulturelle unternehmungen
meine frage ist dabei aber dass zum
beispiel ich dann relativ jung ist mit
dem impfen relativ spät dran ist also
bedeutet das für mich dass ich in diesem
sommer jetzt nicht mehr reisen darf
zumindest nach schweden mehr einreisen
darf
ich bin ja selbst geschrieben und das
heißt es wird noch eine weile dauern bis
ich mit der impfung an der reihe bin
wird es für mich trotzdem wie möglich
sein im sommer nach schweden oder werde
ich dann warten bis nächstes jahr
ich glaube dass sie diesen sommer noch
nicht einreisen können weil wir dann
eben noch die vorgabe haben dass sie
wahrscheinliche geimpft sein müssen und
wir hoffen dass bis dahin aber auch die
schwedischen bürgerinnen bürgern über 18
jahre dann auch schon vor dem sommer
durch kämpft worden sind okay also bist
du irgendwann hat gerade gesagt dass es
noch nicht diese einschränkungen gibt
dass ich praktisch als nicht geimpfte
einreisen darf aber mit diesem pass
könnte es dann dazu kommen meine nächste
frage ist aber in schweden sind die
zahlen relativ niedrig die
infektionszahlen im moment trotzdem
obwohl die schulen immer noch geöffnet
sind und es kein lockdown gibt wie bei
uns aber wie wie das funktioniert das
würde ich jetzt gerne müsste jemand
fragen sie haben keinen block darum die
spuren
nicht aber warum sind die zahlen beim
schweden nach wie vor so niedrig nun das
hängt immer davon ab womit man das
vergleicht aber ich glaube das
hauptanliegen ist dass wir immer die
richtige soziale distanz bewahren
zueinander und das wir von zu hause aus
arbeiten so das möglich ist das sind
wohl die wichtigsten maßnahmen um diese
krankheit einzugrenzen aber es gibt
natürlich auch restriktionen und
einschränkungen für restaurants im
öffentlichen nahverkehr aber wir haben
keinen lockdown weil wir möchten dass
unsere gesellschaft weiterhin
funktioniert und wir möchten nicht dass
die heilung schlimmer ist als die
erkrankung selbst genau und damit geben
wir jetzt zurück nach berlin
ja vielen dank annika und wir haben es
gerade gehört und schweden hofft man
dass vorm sommer bereits alle über 18
geimpft werden können das würde
natürlich einen eindeutig besser
irgendwann mal bedeuten wir sind
gespannt vielen dank noch mal an die
garage in schweden für uns